these attacks I just don't think they're
working and I think Trump kind of knows
they're not working Ben Shapiro had an
interesting tweet about the attacks he
wrote Trump's attacks on DeSantis are
his name's Rob so in a lot of these
posts he calls him Rob Des Sanctus okay
I don't know so I don't know what the
difference between Iran and Rob is but
okay uh he has a bad personality I mean
I I just don't see that he uh here is an
AI simulation of a Twitter spaces
including DeSantis musk Hitler Soros and
Satan I'll get to that one in just a sec
DeSantis is too conservative on
entitlements hey wasn't Charlie Crist
great now you might be wondering about
the what the Hitler what now so Trump uh
right after the Twitter spaces we're
just going to show you like 10 seconds
of this on Instagram he put up a fake
Twitter space and pretended that Elon
Musk and Ron DeSantis and sax and
everybody else were in a Twitter space
with George Soros Klaus Schwab Cheney
Adolf Hitler Satan himself and the FBI
are we playing any video on that yeah
we're going to play some video on that
here you go
hi everyone Welcome to our Rhonda
Sanders Twitter space Hello is my
microphone working correctly George can
you just wait while we hello can you
hear me we can all hear you George can
you just hold on for a second I don't
think they can hear me here you find
George just speak to him I don't think
George knows how to use Twitter hello
can you hear me now can I please make my
big announcement now everyone just hello
okay so like it might be funny to some
degree like I'm kind of personally
overthinking these things are funny and
and they're look I love the meme Wars
and all of that stuff and there really
was a use for all of it but again are we
still gonna do that
or are we going to be a more mature
country are we going to say what's true
fight for what is good like actually
restore America or are we going to just
be about memes and destruction and oh my
God here's a Twitter space where
DeSantis is talking to Hitler
I don't know again this is up to all of
us to decide literally I don't like
collectivism but it is collectively up
to all of us if we are going to get out
of this thing that we have been in for
quite some time
[Music]